you're telling me that you've done 300  videos and they still only get 20 or 30  views all right couple things you've  made enough content with not enough  views where my normal talk of like your  being impatient goes out the window it's  really tough to give this advice because  it almost comes across as hurting one's  feelings but on the flip i'm actually  excited about it you are very rare  you've gone hard enough long enough  around a certain way that you've given  me the opportunity to give rare advice  which is hey you can't do that [ __ ] no  more  you have to completely switch it up that  has been proven to me with those numbers  as it does not work don't dwell that  that's happening but you definitely need  to mix something up with your content  you got to try different [ __ ] that  doesn't need to be devastating like oh  if nobody likes me or i suck that needs  to be how do i make different content